la costa oeste de norteamérica registra
desde junio temperatura récord con los
termómetros canadienses marcando hasta
49 grados centígrados récords a los que
siguió la temporada de incendios los
peores en eeuu donde hay más de 80 focos
activos autoridades y científicos
empiezan a identificar vínculos entre
estos desastres y el cambio climático la
organización mundial del clima dijo que
los desastres relacionados con el agua
dominan la lista de desastres en
pérdidas humanas y económicas que en los
últimos 50 years
españa e italia también enfrentan
incendios forestales
mientras que en el occidente de alemania
y bélgica las inundaciones destruyeron
ciudades y edificios que llevaban más de
un siglo en pie y dejaron al menos 200
muertos
las inundaciones que colapsaron la
ciudad china de xian se registraron en
un día la cantidad de precipitaciones
que suele ser registrada en un año en
india según las autoridades
meteorológicas durante esta temporada
del monzón cayó la mayor cantidad de
lluvia de los últimos 40 años